Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"Why I'm a Grinch" stories
from you guys.
This first one here is from
@flappernapple.
[ Laughter ]
-Flap her na-- Oh, napple.
-Yeah.
-Napple, okay.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
He says...
[ Laughs ] Not bad.
-Hey.
-I love Uno.
-Hey, man.
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from @derekthinks.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Wow! That is --
-Wow!
-That is -- That is awesome.
That is pretty great, man.
Oh, my gosh. That's --
-"Derekthinks" he's evil.
-That's pretty grinchy.
That's good.
This one's from @v-i-price.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
-"A new car?!"
-"A jump rope
and a pack of Uno?"
This one's from @JillsNPotions.
She says...
[ Applause ]
This last one here is
from @Maureenlast. She says...
There you go. Those are
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.